everybody welcome to the show we have
got such a fantastic guest today he is a
hilarious man of many talents and you
can see him starring in Grand Cru which
is all the rage and here's a fun fact he
saw 30 Broadway shows in one single
summer what was his favorite let's ask
him it's Echo Kelly
thank you
we have to talk about it 30 shows in one
summer yeah when was this last summer
and what was the best out of all 30
shows I saw a show called strange Loop
five times of course yes strangely yeah
yeah it was it was just so phenomenal I
think it was more like I was catching up
for all the years I didn't have Broadway
growing up in a way so I just moved out
to New York two summers ago and it's
been Broadway's like one of my favorite
things I get to do how do you like
living in New York I love it I love it
it's such a energetic City I feel like
the people are really great the art
scenes incredible music is great food is
awesome yeah there's nowhere like it
nowhere I mean the rats are friendly
well yeah they're friendly they'll give
you directions
it's true I seen those big fat juicy
rats oh God
I'm out here with those strange skin
like tail
I just kind of stop and then you're like
Live and Let Live yeah have you guys
heard of a rat king what's a rat king
yes yes I I there was like a cover story
of New Yorker magazine or New York
Magazine yeah do I want to know what a
rat king is will you inform us because
I've heard the term but I don't know
exactly what it means yeah so it's
basically when all these rats tails get
intertwined with each other from just
all the like mess or whatever and they
act as one symbiotic creature
it's wild I find that really wild cool
and endearing I don't like Ross's I
don't like it I don't like it at all
thank you for coming Echo well I have to
say I've seen all three of us should
intertwine our Tails right now okay and
and tell some news stories
by the way Avatar the whole tale
in the positive direction all right you
could do that it is time to hit the
headlines Echo will you kick us off of
course come on our fellow rat tail yes
as the middle rat tail okay billboard
reports that the most popular artists on
the planet is can I get a drum roll
please
the weekend yes yes give it up yeah
now Guinness World Records crowned the
Starboy King by looking at Spotify
streaming data the weekend has
112.7 million monthly listeners wow and
second and third place are Miley and
Ariana Grande with 83 and 82 million
respectively and I am in last place
I I
um you're in first place as far as we're
concerned of course
um you know that's really interesting
like fun facts I love the weekend
so much and as far as I'm concerned the
weekend being the winner works for me
works for me too I looked into it oh you
did yeah because I was like I was
curious like who my most listened to
artists were on my and I swear Spotify
thinks I'm a teenage girl because it's
like Taylor Swift and Ariana Grande and
Lady Gaga and Adele and I'm just
emotional and uh you know going through
puberty apparently wow wow yeah who do
you think you're a top Spotify listener
artist is
um I I oh I don't know I'm like a huge
playlist girl so I'm sort of like always
pulling a song here or there I do love
trusting those apps you know what I mean
to tell me what to listen to I recommend
yeah yeah because I like to just like
when you're walking around New York City
stepping over a rat king it's just like
who's gonna come on next yeah exactly I
do do you have a particular artist you
gravity all right there's a few I would
say Spotify thinks I'm an older woman in
the age of 60 or 70. I don't know why
because I'm listening like Paul Simon
a lot of Elton John the old Jackson Five
stuff like that so I dig in the comment
I listen to people like logic and
Childish Gambino and Drake and stuff
like that too but yeah my spot a lot my
Spotify list definitely Paul Simon was
up there it says so much about you who's
on your list I want to listen to your
Spotify
for sure all right well in fashion news
the guardian reports Bros are bringing
back the brooch I tried to hook them
together I tried to rat tail that
um okay the accessory uh granny made
famous is popping up all over the red
carpet look at those beautiful handsome
gentlemen right there that's Russell
Wilson John Cho Michael B Jordan
um they'd be broaching and in honor of
this fashion moment I mean Echo you are
sort of broaching with your beautiful
like sparkling chains that are just ugh
Perfection
we brought out some brooches I have some
here okay Echo we got you look this one
is just a little it's an E look how cute
that's cursive E for you that's what my
name starts with
I know let's get it on here look at that
somewhere roach me up roach me I'm all
about brooches Barrymore we got you a
macaroni and cheese brochure
I've never in my life seen a brooch more
suited
spotify's got nothing on how much this
brooch understands me and knows me and
sees me
I got myself a little froggy one look at
this because it goes with my outfit
it's very cute oh God I can't oh dude I
love when a guy wears a little something
you know what I mean like the brooches
come on yes I do please Echo I trust you
I stabbed you I don't care this will be
the worst will you tell me about the new
season of grand crew because I I have to
say I'm so happy for you thank you
because people
really look at this show with a lot of
admiration it's really critically
acclaimed it's well loved it Harkens
back to some of our you know favorite
group Friends shows that we haven't
really had around for a while and you
guys are bringing it back thank you yeah
I mean it's a fun hangout comedy we
definitely try to lean into the
situational aspects of some of the
comedy we borrow off of a lot of the old
classic hangout shows whether it's
Living Single or Seinfeld
Seinfeld friends
you know there's even a little bit of
sex in the cities in there too I mean
that was one of the biggest Inspirations
for making the show with sex in the city
and a lot of those old uh hangout
sitcoms and we pay homage to a lot of
those in the season I can't wait for
everyone to see how it all comes out
well and we like to see ourselves we
like to see situations like that make us
think or that we relate to or wonder
what we would do if we were oh my God
this brochure I was just gonna say yeah
you are actually pulling off the map
macaroni and cheese brooch and I can't
believe yeah you did it Echo I can't
depressed for me to get this right
perfect
[Applause]
are streaming now on peacock
[Music]
foreign